Перевищення дозволеної швидкості на 10-20 кілометрів -
це майже норма для водіїв у Києві.
Навіть з новими правилами у новому році,
коли у населених пунктах дозволена швидкість - 50.
Річ у тому, що за перевищення швидкості до 20 кілометрів
в Україні досі не було жодних штрафів -
лише усне попередження.
Кабмін вже запропонував парламенту зменшити поріг толерантності
із двадцяти до десяти, ближче до європейської практики.
Але чи є така "межа толерантності" у Європі
і що там буде за "їзду по-українськи"?
Якщо їхати 60-70 кілометрів на годину там, де дозволено лише 50,
німецькому водієві доведеться заплатити штраф
35 євро.
Оштрафують, якщо автівку з перевищеною швидкістю зафіксував радар.
Межа толерантності у населених пунктах - лише 3 кілометри перевищення.
Якщо по місту пересуватися зі швидкістю 80 км/годину,
то доведеться заплатити вже 100 євро штрафу.
А за 100 кілометрів на годину по місту
"світить" позбавлення водійських прав на один місяць
та 200 євро штрафу.
При цьому ФРН - ще відносно ліберальна країна в плані штрафів для водіїв.
Тут жодної допустимої межі толерантності взагалі немає.
Переслідується перевищення ліміту навіть на один-два кілометри.
А за 70 по місту замість 50 - 100 євро штрафу.
Особливість нідерландських доріг –
рівномірний рух транспорту,
тут рідко хтось обганяє на великій швидкості.
Менша відповідно і кількість жертв ДТП.
Голландія - серед лідерів за безпекою руху в Європі.
Тут за додаткові 20 кілометрів -
штраф 150 євро
Розганятися до 100 км по місту можуть лише ті,
у кого є зайві 500 євро.
За користування мобілкою за кермом - ще 160 євро.
Ця романтична скандинавська країна - рекордсмен за штрафами.
По місту 70 кілометрів на спідометрі
можуть обійтися у 500 євро.
Навіть 5 кілометрів перевищення - це вже 50 євро штрафу.
А за 86 км на годину і вище в населеному пункті
у Норвегії загрожує позбавлення водійських прав.